learn my combo and get a threo video
from me that's right in this tutorial
I'm going to guide you through how to do
this combo right here and if you get it
down you can send me a request for a
threep trick to learn and post video of
myself Drex here from Drex Factor Poise
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today I am taking you through
my first po combo Challenge in a long
long time and hopefully we'll both get
something fun out of it but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroar light toys
spinballs and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all of these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- bus
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so I
wrote a fun poy dance combo to After
Hours by Kalani last week and I'd figure
if I were going to put out a challenge
how about I make it interesting one of
the most common requests that I get from
people is to see me spend more three so
I figure maybe there's a way that I can
give youall what you want and we both
get something that makes us happy out of
the bargain so here's the rules learn my
combo and post video of it to the
platform of your choice and make sure to
tag me when I drop into the comments to
see how you did you can request the
three po trick of your choice for me
within reason of course I don't really
po juggle so please don't request like a
reverse Subs mess or any such nonsense
from me that's not cool I'll even make
it easier on you all by using contact
boy instead of my usual Socko for this
one so it'll slow me down a wee bit so
if y'all are in let's go talk about what
tricks you'll need for this
one so this combo is built up into
several different sections with
basically a different theme trick in
each one but all the sections are built
around being able to spin py tricks that
work in Split Time same direction so
knowing how to keep a stable split Time
same direction in both wheel plane as
well as wall plane is going to be
absolutely essential to you as for
specific tricks that you're going to
need to know for each different section
first and foremost it's going to be
helpful to know how to do Buzz saws if
will also be helpful to know how to do
split times same direction in spin
flowers both in wall plane as well as in
wheel plane in addition you'll also want
to know how to do stall Chasers and one
of my very favorites you're going to
want to know how to do waist stps that
is being able to Do complete turns while
you're performing a 3B weave from a
forwards weave to a reverse weave and
then back again there is also an option
for this combo of performing a more
advanced version of it that will require
you to to know how to do a simple
contact roll that is going across the
backs side of your forearm and while it
is not a pyric per se there's also a
dance technique that I use a lot in this
particular combo called a tandu this
involves being able to just point out
your toe and tap the ground in a variety
of different directions so having a good
grasp of that will also be helpful I
will include links to tutorials for all
these tricks down in the description as
well as a playlist of them up in the
cards
awesome so first up let me show you the
combo and then I will break it down for
you piece by piece we don't got to take
it slow I'm going hit the gas if you
ready to go I want to fit s breathing
through your clothes the way you touch
my neck got me ready to
fall I want to make magic I want you to
feel me I want you to gra it I want you
to steal me if you want it you can have
it I want you to free me I'm not trying
to lock you
down okay so the biggest thing to
understand about this combo is that it's
choreographed like a tick tock dance
there are going to be eight counts of
eight in the music that we are
performing this piece to and each of
them is going to have a different trick
or theme to it for the most part it's
going to be just you doing that same
trick for the entire eight count with
one or two exceptions and adding a
little bit of dance on top of it so I'm
going to give you each section one by
one so you can drill them in isolation
and then we're going to work on putting
them all together all right so let's
take a look at our first eight count
here this is going to be what kind of
looks a little bit to me like a salsa
step that we're going to do as we're
spinning our POI split times same
direction in wheel plane like so here's
how we break this down so the steps go
like this you're going to think it's
going to be one 2 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4
5 6 78 and swish your hips on one
2 5
six one
2 5 six and you step
forward as you switch the hips and step
back when you switch the hips again if
you keep the Poise spinning entire time
you wind up
with 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 you
can just drill this by itself to get a
feel for it and when you're ready to
move on the transition to the next
section happens as such after you take
those steps back on your five six you've
got a moment to to rest on seven and
then your eight is going to be stalling
your right po up and your left po down
and you're going to pop out your left
knee as that happens so here's what that
looks like we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and
then we switch over to our Buzz saws for
our next measure cool so measure number
two now we did our stall and we brought
our left hand po up and over to our
right right hand side we're spinning a
forwards Buzz saw pointing it off to
Stage right now you notice as I'm doing
this I'm kind of leaning back with my
right foot straight out in front of me
and my left foot bent so most of my
weight is back here on my left foot I
want you to go from this on one two to
leaning in on 3 4 when you lean in I
want you to lean in with your chest and
stick your butt out yeah so we're going
back and forth between leaning back like
this leaning forward like this back like
this forward like this the counts will
be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 again 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
all right so for our third eight count
we're going to switch from having our
buz saw over here on stage right to
opening up with our hands and po out to
either side of us in Split Time same
direction um you're going to do all of
your counts when the PO are slipping
past each other in the middle I tried
choreographing this with them on the
outside cuz I think it's slightly easier
but it just didn't look right so we're
going to go through a series of
positions here where we have 1 2 3 4 5 6
coming around 78 is where we uh land and
we're doing stalls out with the POI to
either side so again we have 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 we sweep around on seven we poke out
on eight so what exactly are our feet
doing while our hands are doing these
wonderful flowers I'm so glad you asked
because now we're into our first section
of tondos yay so the big thing to
realize here is that you're going to go
through a series of positions where your
left foot and specifically your left
toes are tapping around to different
positions around you while your left
foot stays more or less in place you're
basically using that as an anchor and
then moving your left toe out to tap
different spots around you specifically
we're going to go reaching the left foot
behind tapping the ground kind of
diagonally back behind the right foot on
one two we're going to reach the left
foot out to tap straight out to stage
left on 3 four we kind of wrap the left
foot around in front of the right foot
on 5 six and then we do a little triple
step on 78 you want to think of it is
seven and eight and we wind up in a
place where we've got the right foot in
front and the left foot behind and and
our legs kind of twisted up like this so
here's all that together we do 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 and that is the end of that
measure all right so that takes us to
measure number four and this is a Choose
Your Own Adventure there's a more
advanced version of this and there's a
more accessible version of this so you
can choose which one you prefer but the
long and short of it is we're starting
from this position where we have our
legs crossed and our po out to either
side and on the one we're taking a turn
around notice I'm basically untwisting
my legs turning around to face upstage
and then retwisting my legs coming
around to face downstage and then I'll
have a little step here where I have to
kind of readjust and as I'm doing that
cool turn Boom the PO are just pointing
out I'm holding my hands about even with
my neck there is actually a vocal cue in
the music that mentions the word neck
and that's where this little bit came
from
aren't I clever but when you land you're
trying to land in a place where both of
the PO are pointed over to your stage
left side so we're going from them
pointing out in either direction to them
both landing on the side of you so the
next part of this section gets a little
bit interesting if you're doing the
standard version of the combo here's how
it goes once you have landed both of
your POI over to stage left and you have
brought your right leg out to the side
you're going to reach your right leg
over to to do a little tondu uh Crossing
in front of your left foot and as you do
that you're also going to take your poy
in your right hand bring it around and
then do a stall up this all happens on
the five so it's like a 56 and then a 78
happens when you open up your foot and
stall back out with that right hand po
so altogether it looks like this we went
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 like so and if you want
the hard version of that rather than
taking the stall around and then back
out we're instead going to do a contact
roll like so so the counts if you're
doing the contact roll look like this we
go around on 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and you're
going to start with the PO already
spinning on the next measure and that
brings us to measure number five
congratulations you are halfway there
now this is going to involve a little
bit of kind
of fancy
footwork put together with some stall
Chasers one of my favorite po tricks so
let's see how we get this done so here's
what the footwork looks like for this
we're going to have a standing leg that
is our base of support when we start
each count and we're going to have a
foot that's kind of sticking out in
tondu and what happens is we pull in the
leg that was doing a tandu in this case
it's my right foot so we can put our
weight on it take a step we step behind
it with the other foot in this case the
left we step out with the right foot and
then boom do a little tap SL tondu with
the left foot now notice the left foot
started off as the one that was our
standing leg and is now the leg doing
the tandu so that means when we go back
to the other side we're going to do the
opposite we're going to bring back in
the Left Foot Right Foot reaches behind
us left foot steps and tandue out with
the right foot so the counts for this
wind up being 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 try and see if you can put a
little bit of Bounce in this as you're
doing it so let's do that with our stall
tracers now in five 6 78 we have 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and this takes
us measure number six which is another
one of those measures where you can just
practice it on Loop by yourself to get a
feel for it and this is just performing
two pedal ins spin flowers in Split Time
same direction the trick here is that
all the footwork is triple steps that is
as we're taking our steps we want to be
thinking triple step triple step triple
step triple step note that whenever I do
that I'm switching off which foot is
going to be first the next time I take a
a step so given that our last measure
was one of stall Chasers we're coming
from a spot where we have our right POI
stalled up and our right foot pointed
out in tandu so you're going to imagine
that this starts by going over and
stepping on your right foot and then
bringing your left hand up above your
head for the first pedal of that inpin
flower so we're going to have triple
step triple step triple step triple step
as we move our way over to Stage right
and if you can try and arrange your body
just slightly to the side as you're
taking these steps if for no other
reason then it gives us a really nice
silhouette to see in the process and now
we have measure number seven we are
almost home free here and this entire
measure is nothing but us performing
waist straps back and forth and stalling
out from each of them we're basically
doing shaes as we're going back and
forth with them like
so so just practicing the waist strap
part of this you want to think that
you're going around ground in a circle
from forwards to reverse to forwards
once again and then stalling one po up
and one po down and then coming back
through stepping around stalling out
stepping around stalling out if you can
take your hands up and down through that
midsection to really add some level
changes to add some interest here the
counts for this one are that we're
looking to start each waist strap on one
and perform the stall on the four so
we're looking at 1 2 3 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 just like that and again
remember you can drill this back and
forth to get comfortable with it before
integrating it with the rest of the
combo and that takes us to measure
number eight hooray we're finally home
and this one is going to be easier than
the other measures cuz there's actually
only four counts that you have to be
aware of for it we wind up finishing
measure number seven with our right po
pointing up and our left po pointing
down so what we're going to do from here
is work our way back to center stage and
wrap the PO around our hands in a spiral
wrap the counts for this wind up being
just 1 2 3 4 I want to wind up with my
left foot kind of reaching outward and
my toes pointing up and I want to focus
change to the camera on the four awesome
so let me show you the standard version
of the whole combo from top to bottom
with the music so you can see how all
the pieces fit together ready let's
[Music]
go five six 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3
4 there you
[Music]
go hit the gas if you ready to go I want
to fit a SW breathing through your
clothes the way you touch my neck got me
ready to
fall I want to make magic I I want you
to feel me I want you to gra it I want
you to steal me if you want it you can
have it I want you fre
[Music]
I'm awesome I cannot wait to see y'all's
version of this combo quick reminder
post video of yourself doing it to the
social media platform of your choice and
make sure to tag me when I show up in
the comments you can request your trick
then and if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to to make sure that
other people can find it and of course
to help my channel grow hey gang one
other quick note before I set you loose
and that's to let you know that I'm
about to start up a new round of live
stream poy dance classes these classes
are designed to take your PO dance to
the next level not only will I give you
in-depth instruction on a variety of
different po tricks and how to dance
them up we'll also talk about transition
points between different tricks and I'll
be giving you a piece of choreography
intended to bring all the different
pieces together you'll get to join a
community of point ansers from all
across the world flowing and growing
together registration is open now and
our first class is June 25th plus which
if you register before June 18th you
qualify for early bird tickets sign up
now at crowdcast doio drexfactor poy for
tuck turns Tango see you
[Music]
there this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you one and all
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one easy way to do that
you can sign on up over at patreon at
patreon.com Factor po there you can get
access to a whole host of amazing
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping my me out in my mission to
bring po spinning and flow Arts to the
whole wide world go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to check out some of the other po combo
challenges I put together over the years
I'm going to leave a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up on screen I've got a whole
bunch of different skill levels
available so you might find something
that's right up your alley thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today I hope it involves
learning this combo and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace